has your question okay so all right
you've you've never been proposed to not
really not like that no okay okay so if
you were if you had this amazing mindset
you're 32 did you have kids no okay so
do you know what your chances below 50
of having a child possibly but if you're
if you're single at 30 your chances like
40 of having a kid so you're more likely
to never have children I got 30 and a 32
that means you're three years away from
geriatric pregnancy wow like so that
means if you're single today you gotta
find a guy in three years to agree to
marry you
um and agree to get in a long-term
relationship marry you and then have a
kid or just get pregnant